hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well during the era in
which Epictetus was first studying and
then applying and then finally teaching
stoic philosophy one of the great rival
schools was that of the Epicureans
and both stoicism and Epicureanism were
in fact philosophical schools but they
also [ __ ] found ways to sort of leech
themselves into the broader culture so
quite a few people who were not
philosophers would identify with one or
another of these schools and the
Epicureans were viewed in many respects
as being at the opposite end of the
spectrum from the Stoics they actually
did have quite a few things in common
and then from the skeptic perspective
they're both considered to be dogmatic
philosophies they were both
materialistic philosophies and that they
they don't think that there is any sort
of irreducible soul that's not material
so they think that the you know the
divine is in some way material but were
they really different was about their
vision of the whole point of human
existence the nature of the good and so
the stomach's has said that the good
ultimately can be
in terms of virtue moral virtue or in
terms of the ruling Faculty of the
person these these really pull together
and the Epicureans on the getting up
here on the board held that the good was
ultimately pleasure and that means the
bad was ultimately pain so what what
conduced to or produced pleasure was
thereby good and what led to pain was
thereby they happened if you had a
mixture of pain and pleasure that's you
know perhaps neutral or perhaps a little
bit worse or a little bit better
depending on how much you've got mixed
together they also did distinguish
between different kinds of Plenty but
you can see core concept video
specifically on Epicurus about that so
I'm not going to go into that now so the
Epicureans are one of the major non
Socratic schools all the other rival
schools of the Stoics yeah without an
exception are really offshoots of
schools or persons that had studied with
Socrates Epicurus is a different sort of
tradition and we have a Koreans tended
to oppose themselves to pretty much
everybody else I guess but their
pleasures are good and Han is the bad
they were hedonists now makitas
criticizes them at a number of different
points within its discourses about a
number of different topics they are
probably his most common target of
criticism with the academic skeptics
coming in second and he's got a number
of different complaints to make against
them some of them are really on target
some of them perhaps not quite so much
so here's one of them he says that
Epicureans fundamentally misunderstand
pleasures of the soul or the mind the
Epicureans had said that mental
pleasures are pleasures of the soul were
in fact better than purely physical or
bodily pleasures pleasures of the flesh
so you know the pleasure of reading a
book is in some way
is better than the pleasure of going out
and having a night and you know getting
really drunk and then having sex wise
they also thought that some some
pleasures are produced by the absence of
pains again you can see a core concept
video about that but the Stoics flaw at
least Epictetus thought then the
Epicureans didn't really understand the
relationship between pleasure and the
good for the other Koreans they're st.
pleasure is the good so anything that's
good is good insofar as it either
it is pleasure or is pleasant or in some
way able to lead to pleasure in that in
that case that's what we call it useful
or the you know bone to mutilate and in
lack
it's liable to lead to some some results
and the Stoics said no that doesn't
really encompass the whole scope of the
good in this very actually in line with
the Aristotelian 's and and the
plateless as well Epictetus will talk
about pleasure being generated by the
existing good he talked about this yes
he is discussing this with an official
who happens to be an epicurean he says
there we go the goods of the soul first
of all belonging to the sphere the moral
purpose or do they not so they do belong
to that so as the pleasure of the soul
something that belongs in that sphere
and then what produces that do we just
have a pleasure you know because it
produces itself that doesn't really make
sense what does it produce that we must
assume that there is already in
existence a certain antecedent essence
and osya of the good and that was what
we're responding to when we feel
pleasure so when we are
for example cultivating virtue or
conscious on our own freedom as we make
a choice that is putting a
on the right track or contemplating the
progress that we've made we're not those
things are not good because we're
feeling pleasure in looking at them
rather we're feeling pleasure because
those things are good so there's a
fundamental reversal that the Stoics
thing is happening at least with respect
to the pleasures of the mind
they might say so the similar thing
about pleasures of the body but
Epictetus doesn't actually say that per
se now what he does end up saying though
is that the Epicureans aren't really
about pleasures of the mind at all what
they really are about is physical
pleasure they just happen to think that
the pleasures of the mind are things
that are derived in some way from the
pleasures of the body and you know this
does make sense if we unpack what he's
saying because Epictetus are Epicurus to
talk for example about you know being
able to remember something and take
pleasure in the memory but this is
perhaps an off-base criticism the
Epicureans an unfair criticism that
doesn't really take into account their
well worked out doctrines about the
distinction between maximum physical
pleasures but in any case that is one of
the things that epictetus thinks he
thinks Epicureans when you get down to
it they're not really about mental
pleasures they're really about physical
pleasures and they just kind of candy
coated or put some window-dressing to
make you think that they're talking
about something more elevated there's a
common criticism epicureanism now he
also says something really interesting
in chapter 20 and book 2 he says that
they had received measures and standards
from nature this is when that McTigue
Epicurus himself did he says a man is
received from nature measures and
standards for discovering the truth so
you know but I'm looking at what we do
take pleasure in and what we do take
pain from we are learning something
about the way human beings work and the
way that we relate to reality so he says
but then
this person doesn't go on and take the
pains to add to these and work out
additional principles to supply the
deficiencies instead he does exactly the
opposite endeavoring to take away and
destroy whatever faculty he does possess
for discovering the truth and he uses
examples there for of piety and sanctity
so you know the Stoics thought that we
human beings can reason out the
existence of gods who actually do care
about human beings the Epicureans
thought that were gods but they don't
care anything about human beings because
otherwise they wouldn't have a pleasant
life right having a pleasant light it
means not being tied up with our
nonsense
out here in the earth and so Epictetus
says to Epicurus Wow a nice doctrine
buddy
I mean think of what you just did for
all the young people you just told them
God doesn't care about what they do you
know how's that gonna work itself out
you're almost better off they're saying
there's no gods whatsoever so he thinks
that the Epicureans are learning from
you know sort of the same stock of
general ideas and human nature then the
Stewart's are drawing upon but they're
not going far enough and they're
trimming away some of the important
other experientially based principles or
experientially grasped principles than
the Stoics themselves are contributed
another thing that you really goes after
them on has to do with with family life
and social life the Epicureans we're
very different from the Stoics in that
the Epicureans council withdrawing
yourself as much as possible from
political or social life so you know
that's just not running for office but
don't belong to clubs or anything like
that in part because it would make your
life more tranquil and they also thought
if you can avoid getting married and
having children you should do so now
there's several things
Athena says about this by way of
criticism
one is Epictetus thinks that there is in
fact a natural affection that parents
have for their children it can you know
be damaged it can be faced but we do
have a sort of inclination to take care
of and to love our progeny so he thinks
that the Epicureans have gone wrong and
not acknowledging that he thinks we also
have a sort of natural social instinct
to connect up with other human beings no
that doesn't mean we can't be jerks to
them right you become envious and
rivalries and all sorts of other things
but we also do have a natural tendency
to want to live in society together and
to try to get along he thinks of the
Epicureans just don't recognize that and
they're going wrong in their philosophy
by doing so the other thing that he
really says that he stresses is well
what if they put those doctrines into
practice universally you wouldn't have
any human society because there's really
two main things there's a lot of other
things as well but there's two main
things that you need in order to have a
perpetuation of the human race people
have to have kids which means they
having sexual relations if they're not
getting married just every society has
some sort of regulation of sexual
relations that we can call marriage if
they're if they're not reproducing no
more humans after a while right and all
bets are off the other thing is you know
we're not just about reproducing we have
a whole social world we have culture and
that is a product of societies so we do
have to have some people who are willing
to step up and say take political office
or carrying out the difficult work of
legislation or enforcement of the laws
so he goes on and he says here we go
you go that he says what would have
stuck what would a epicurean state be
like how would we in fact live out this
sort of life I don't know the exact
passage in front of us
nobody would want to do anything
everybody would withdraw as much as
possible just to preserve their own
pleasure from all these things that are
required for making human society
function and continue so these are some
pretty serious complaints there's one
other one that he puts in there along
with these ones of a pleasure which is
that the Epicureans essentially
instrumentalize all the goods that are
out there and that is not only an error
in the sense of getting things wrong
about you know why justice matters but
it should also tell us you don't want to
walk down a dark alley with an epicurean
the Epicureans would say following
Epicurus the reason why you shouldn't
commit injustice is because you can't be
sure that you're not going to get
punished an epoch Tina says there's
plenty of people who can be totally sure
that they're not going to get punished
you know they commit their crimes in
ways that make it impossible for them to
be detected or they use their influence
or money or power or connections to not
have to deal with any consequences so if
you're going to say that it's mainly the
punishment that we need to be concerned
with and not not doing injustice because
injustice is a bad thing
hey I don't want to have to you know
rely on you buddy because you're one
step away from being unjust so these are
a lot of serious criticisms of the
Epicurean position like I said a few of
them seem to be a bit off base but many
of them target some pretty vital areas
of the Unruh Kurian doctrine